[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم في العشب
أعتقد ذلك بفضل الصناعة
سيتم فصل صناعة العطور عن هذا
التي كان من المقدر لها أن تكون منذ ذلك الحين
الطريق اسمي جان بول جوبيرت
وأنا مزارع الورد مرة أخرى
منذ أن ولدت الدولار وما
كانت الأسرة من أوائل من عملوا على الزراعة
حول الورود
1840s 8850 محاكمات مبكرة
إنه يرضي الرئيس منذ البداية
تتفتح وتتفتح هو
الوقت ولكن اليوم اليوم
عادي وجامعي الرياح
اختيار الناس ويتم طهيها
نذهب إلى سقيفة نضعها في
الحقائب ويذهب إلى البئر الصناعي
لا يزال يرضي واحد فقط
2.2 لجعل الإنتاج في غاية
زراعة الورد الراقية
هذا ما أفعله سأستمر
بضع سنوات أخرى لأنني 62
أعوام
اسمي فريدريك دابي نحن
حقًا في دمار محتمل
من الوردة نفسها من الواضح أن
ما لهم من ثروة
و
الجودة على مستوى الجوانب وهو
سعى للغاية بعد ذلك مرة واحدة
كانت خطوات الغسيل الثلاث
تفعل يوميا سيكون هناك
حتى الورد الورد ونذهب
تتراكم في المبخر حتى
حقًا ننتقل إلى الخطوة الأخيرة
تركيزك في النهاية لعقد
الخرسانة
لذلك يتطلب الأمر 600 كيلوغرام لإنتاج كيلوغرام واحد
مقتطفات وأود أن أقول الدراما أ
غرام صغير من المستخلص حوالي 41
46 22
وذلك بفضل البركة في جوهرها
طمئن الماضي
[موسيقى]